okay so I I want to lay this out now
just to get it on the record relatively
early normally I don't comment about an
election that's not the immediate next
election so in 2017 people would call in
and they'd say hey what do you think
about 2020 this that and I'd say we have
to focus on 2018 that's the immediate
question right now what happens in 2018
but I actually do want to talk about
2024 today a little bit because I worry
that there's lots of people just missing
what's taking place and not seeing what
is increasingly a very disturbing
situation the bottom line is this I
believe that if there's a so-called
rematch in 24 between Trump and Biden
that that's very very bad for Joe Biden
I don't think that looks good and if Joe
Biden chooses not to run for re-election
uh and uh it is Kamala Harris instead
who is the Democratic Presidential
nominee I think that that also doesn't
look very good and I'm going to lay out
why now I'm going to mention Joe Biden's
age here
Joe Biden would be 82 at the time of the
2024 election Donald Trump would also be
78 at that time and one might argue
there's really not that much difference
it's just two old white guys but the
difference is that Donald Trump has a
cult of followers a cult of personality
around him that afflicts his supporters
for whom Trump's age is not going to be
a factor while I believe that because of
the nature of Joe Biden's support and
because of the nature particularly of
the progressive wing of the democratic
party and the preferences of democratic
voters the idea of voting for an 82 year
old in 2024 is going to impact those
more predisposed to vote for Joe Biden
then it will affect those likely or
considering voting for Donald Trump in
2024. so in other words what I'm saying
is Biden's age will work against him
more than Trump's age will work against
Trump so let's now get into my thought
process first and foremost I'm getting
the sense just that a base level
that in general a so-called rematch is
going to be very tough for Joe Biden and
in addition to the concept of a rematch
or one of our Reddit viewers uh put a
post up on our Reddit that calls it like
a sort of final showdown I think that it
will invigorate the right far more than
it will invigorate the left that's one
scenario the final showdown rematch
between Trump and Biden I don't think
it's very good for Joe Biden now there's
a different scenario that's possible
which is that Joe Biden as some suspect
might not run for a second term in 2024
and then Kamala Harris will either be
handed or might have to fight for the
Democratic nomination there's still a
long time until 2024 but all of those
scenarios I think are also problematic
Kamala Harris has maintained a
relatively low profile so far and she
has low approval ratings that doesn't
give me much confidence about Harris
versus Trump in 2024. if you look at the
latest Real Clear Politics average of
approval polls Kamala Harris is now
underwater her negatives her disapproval
is higher than her approval
For Better or Worse she's taken some
real hits when it comes to her handling
of the border now you might say what
handling rightly or wrongly Joe Biden
tasked her with the Border problem her
approval on that is very low now it's
early things could change between now
and 2024 but as of right now
I am not at all confident that if Kamala
Harris is just handed the Democratic
nomination meaning Biden says I'm not
running but Kamala Harris is running and
no serious Democratic primary takes
place and she's the nominee I don't
think Harris does well against Donald
Trump in 2024. in fact I find it really
difficult to see a scenario where she
wins now the other scenario would be Joe
Biden says he's not running
and Harris does run but there's a big
primary fight which Kamala Harris
ultimately wins because of her low
approval if Kamala Harris has to fight
her way through an ugly primary to get
that nomination
it also strikes me as a recipe for
disaster similar to 2016. the third
scenario would be Biden doesn't run
Kamala fights for the nomination but she
loses and someone else is the Democratic
nominee that I do think is too early to
talk about and we we just have no idea
who that might be we have no idea how
they might match up against Donald it's
just too hypothetical but the two
scenarios I'm focused on which are the
the problematic ones which are Biden
does run for re-election or Biden
doesn't and kamala's the nominee whether
she just gets it handed to her or she
fights for it and wins it if you give me
an even money bet today
I'm probably betting on Trump in those
scenarios based on what I currently see
as the energy of the democratic party
and the energy of the Republican Party
part of it is that even in 2020 right
there's this urgent emergency of
removing Donald Trump uh uh the and the
the energy and enthusiasm around Biden
was relatively muted now Biden
fortunately won by many millions of
votes nationally but it was small
differences in just a few States if they
had gone the other way Trump would have
won it it's similar to Trump winning in
16 if just a few States went slightly
differently Hillary Clinton would have
been uh the winner in 2016. so that also
makes me concerned with Trump four years
in the rear view mirror that there will
be again Democrats who after eight years
of Obama said I'm not for whatever
reason I'm not going to go out and vote
in this Hillary versus Trump thing and
then Trump won a repeat of that also
scares me and then in addition to that
as we see
at these Trump rallies the cult of
personality around Donald Trump the fact
that the Republican Party whether
they're pretending or whether they
seriously like trump it doesn't matter
they're they're basically behind him
they're not abandoning him that is uh
troubling and there is really I mean it
it really seems like there's nothing
Trump can do to lose the support that he
has or at least most of it so I think
2024 is real trouble
in a rematch against Joe Biden or
against Kamala Harris I'm not saying I
have a better idea I think Trump will be
very strong in 24 if he's the the
nominee so if you have a different
perspective I would love to hear from
you and I understand I'm breaking my own
rule I usually only talk about the next
election but the circumstances are
unique and the next election is 22 but
it relates so much to 24 that we really
have sort of like a three-year period
that I see as a package in my mind so
send me your thoughts about this and of
course if 2022 goes disastrously for the
trumpian wing of the Republican party
that weakens Trump dramatically
um but I don't know that that's actually
going to be the outcome so let me know
how worried you are about this if you
agree disagree find me on Twitter at
dpacman one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
Pacman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com Pacman